I saw that you're being investigated
it's the system against the new idea you
know I'm breaking the mold when they
want to shut me out basically my central
theme has been to debate why Artie
crooked you know I've been trying to
engage my profession and debate I'm
saying look listen to word I've got to
say but believe that I want to debate on
why Peter crooked and then we work
upwards something's going wrong with the
way people's faces are growing people
don't want to admit this people want to
believe that the way their face grew
with genetic and yet it's so clearly not
genetic and all the hard evidence says
it's not genetic at least that's the way
we're treating it as if it were caused
by the genetics